А має познайомитися з вами приємність
Христина
майбутні журналісти
не будуть на виставці знімаємо все і
хочемо далі показатися на телеканалі
тиса-1 ваші побажання конкурсантам
виставки І звісно ж нашим глядачам
Минулого року ми разом з колегами
придумали цю ідею провести в найбільшому
палаці
дитячо-юнацької творчості виставку
всеукраїнську виставку країна юних
майстрів Минулого року звичайно
хвилювались цьому році в цьому році
менше було хвилювання Чому Тому що
з'їхались молоді талановиті діти з усіх
регіонів України
ваше студія репрезентує тепле і
Виноградне Закарпаття юних Геологів
приїхали з Донецька юні краєзнавці юні
туристи з усіх областей України і ви
можете тут познайомитесь з своїми
однолітками із Луганська зі Львова з ким
у Криму Донецька ми подивилися сьогодні
чудове видовище парад дитячої творчості
і ми просто радіємо Наскільки в нас
багато талановитих обдарованих дітей Ну
просто генеральних усіх видах творчості
вони переможці спортивних змагань вони
переможці і наукових змагань вони
переможці танцювальних мистецьких тут є
і скульптори і конструктори і хто
створює радіокеровані моделі різні різні
досліди ми подивилися наскільки
багата українська земля просто
обдарованими дітьми і добрими педагогами
наставниками тому що в Україні сьогодні
працює вже про це казав 80000 гуртків в
яких займається майже сорок відсотків
всіх школярів України Це набагато На мою
думку краще і важливіше ніж просто
пустувати втрачати час а тут ми
допомагаємо майбутньому громадянам
молодим громадянам а здобути чи якусь
професію чи творчо розвиватись і це
прекрасно прекрасно що в нас є вже
кілька дитячих телевізійних студій одна
в Києві одна в Ужгороді однак
Дніпропетровську значить про що це
говорить що прийде час і можна буде
проводити якесь творче змагання
найкращий фільм найкращих телепередачу і
визначати авто в нас найкращий режисер
Хто в нас найкращий сценарій хто кращий
журналіст тому я всім хочу побажати
успіхів і сподіваюсь що така
всеукраїнська Країна майстрів стане
доброю традицією наступного року і і В
наступні роки буде і друга і третя друга
сьогодні продовжує роботу буде і третя і
п'ята А колись буде істота і будуть вже
онуки і правнуки тих юних майстрів брати
участь в цих нових країнах тому
творчість взагалі робить людину
безмежною набагато більше Слухай всі
творить усе